I'm going to say
[Silence]
alhamdulillah. These
are
bad.
[Silence]
These verses
are the first verses that the prophet
sallallah sallallah.aii wasallam
received
and were the verses with which he was
sent as a messenger to the people of
Quraysh.
In these verses,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
gives very particular
instructions
on not only the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and sending him as a
messenger to his people,
but specific instructions
with how to organize
his da'wah or his invitation
or his calling of his people to
Islam.
There are things which are haram
and there are things which are more
haram. There are things which are
obligatory and there are those things
which are more obligatory.
There are
issues which are of shik and there
are issues which are of minor shik.
There are issues of major kufur and
minor kufur major vul minor vul major
minor neph etc.
All of these things are the details
which are necessary
in order to
have a fruitful daer.
It's not that all of the commandments
were
you know just sent down upon the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam all at
once. It wasn't just one book that was
sent down to him all at once. It was
organized. It came in parts and it began
with the most important then that which
is important then that which is of of
secondary importance etc.
And so this is why the scholars of Islam
have put so much energy and have
concentrated their efforts so much on
detailing
the order in which the chapters and
verses of the Quran were revealed and
also the sun and narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam as
much as possible because of this order.
This order it doesn't just give us
the order of the prophet's story or a
timeline. It's not just a historical
thing. It's an issue of
it reflects what is most important,
what is of lesser importance, what is
most dire, what is not as dire, etc.
If we understand this,
we
look not only at the order of the
chapters and how they were revealed, but
also the order of the verses.
So we notice first of all that the first
word
or the first five verses that Allah sent
to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam,
they began with the word
which is to read or to recite.
The next group or cluster of verses that
were revealed to him
began with the word
the first command.
Right?
So first we have recite and read. Then
we have stand
up and go forth and give da. What do we
understand from this? What do we learn
from this? We learn from this what imar
understood is one of the core
principles of Islam and that is as
alkari says in his
That knowledge
comes before
action and speech. Before speech and
action, before we attempt to do
something, we first learn how to do it.
We first learn,
then we follow that with action. Any
action that is not predicated on
knowledge is going to be misguided. And
any knowledge that is not succeeded by
action, it is what incurs the anger of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. What do we
recite every day in every of every
salah that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
teaches us
guide us the straight path
the path of those whom your grace is
upon
not the path of those whom your anger is
nor those who have gone astray.
Who are these three types of people?
Every human being.
Every human being at every moment
is every human being who is conscious.
Every human being who has a
consciousness, who has an intention,
every human being who is sane and so
forth of age, they fall into one of
these three categories in some actions.
And generally,
holistically, they fall into one of
these three categories. Number one,
those whom Allah's
grace
favor is upon.
Number two, those whom Allah's anger is
upon. Number three, those who are
misguided.
Who are those whom Allah's
grace is upon?
They are those who know.
They are upon knowledge
and they implement that knowledge.
They are those who know
and act upon that knowledge.
Who are those whom Allah's anger is
upon?
Those
who have knowledge but fail to act on
it. Who are those who have gone astray?
They are those who act upon ignorance.
they do not have knowledge.
So we have the the only type of person
that is successful
are those who have action with
knowledge.
They know and they implement.
Then we have those with the knowledge
but no action. Then we have those with
action and no knowledge.
The more a person has knowledge and
implements that knowledge, the more the
individual becomes guided, the more the
individual incurs grace and favor from
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
So
he says
the chapter regarding
it's one of the chapters in in the
second in the third book of his the book
of knowledge
and that is
that
knowledge comes first
then action and implementation.
then speech. Right? This sounds like
it's a given. It sounds yeah, of
course, how can a person do something
without knowing?
But it is not as obvious as you think.
It's not as obvious as many people
think.
Many people
they are either
learning
and it's it's a kind of abstract
knowledge. It's almost a hobby.
It's almost you know something
that entertains them and so they to
learn. But this knowledge is nothing
more than that. It's it's trivial. It's
very good to to know and to learn but
it's not something that they take
serious enough that they implement it.
On the other hand, there are those who
are very very sincere.
They have a lot of sincerity
and that sincerity drives them to
action.
But action without knowledge is
destructive.
It doesn't matter how good a person's
intention is.
Arguably one of the most dangerous
combinations
is good intentions with no knowledge.
Ignorance and good intentions
breeds chaos and destruction
and it breeds also an illusion of
knowledge.
We have also
the other side which is knowledge that
is abstract.
I learn something but I use it as a
vanity.
And knowledge is just wealth.
It's the same thing. As a matter of
fact, throughout the Quran, Allah
mentions knowledge and wealth together.
Throughout the Sunnah, the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam mentions wealth and
knowledge together.
He says for instance that only two types
of people are worthy of your envy.
One whom Allah has given knowledge to.
He's given the Quran to and he recites
it and implements it and judges by it.
And the second is one whom Allah has
given wealth to and he spends that
wealth for the sake of Allah. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells us
that two types of seekers will never be
satisfied.
Two types of seekers
will never be satisfied.
The seeker of knowledge and the seeker
of wealth. Those two they will never be
satisfied. If you understand this, you
understand that knowledge is a vanity.
It can be a vanity. As a matter of fact,
it is even arguably more of a vanity
than wealth is because the human being
was created to know.
And so that which satisfies us the most
is when we learn.
That which gives us vigor the most is
learning. Whatever it is, whatever that
knowledge is, knowledge in itself is
incredibly powerful in its motivations.
And this is why the greatest insult
arguably as a human being, one of the
things that is the most insulting things
is to be looked at as being ignorant or
looked at as being having a lack of
intelligence. This is something very
insulting to us as human beings. Why?
Because we pride ourselves on our
intelligence, on our knowledge.
Knowledge in Islam is not just a vanity.
It can be, it can become a vanity and it
is very powerful.
However, if a person uses knowledge
as such, this is a this is a person
whose journey to Allah is incomplete.
They have to be together. There has to
be knowledge and there has to be
implementation.
And so when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
teaches us and demands of us that we
repeat over and over throughout our
prayer all through the day at different
times of the day. Guide us the straight
path, the path of those whom your favor
is upon. meaning those who know and
implement. Not those whom your anger is
upon.
Meaning those who know and do not
implement, nor those who have gone
astray, meaning those who do not know
but seek to implement.
One
final point regarding this.
We see that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
always or most usually
mentions knowledge before actions all
through the Quran.
He says subhanahua
those who believe
and work righteous deeds. What is
belief?
Belief begins with knowledge. It's
knowledge. That's what belief is. It is
a knowledge that is held with conviction
in the heart such conviction that it
demands implementation. That's what eman
is.
And Allah mentions throughout the Quran,
believe and work righteous deeds.
Believe and work righteous deeds. They
know and they implement. They know and
they implement. The more a person knows,
if they implement, then the more they
will know. And the more they know, if
they implement, then the more they will
know and so on and so forth.
This is why we are taughtallahillahillah
that is your intention.
None is rightfully worshiped but Allah.
That's the intention.
Those are the good intentions.
But good intentions alone, it's not
enough. What's the second part?
Those are the actions.
That is what the implementation of those
the manifestation when we put those when
we embody those good intentions and
express them. How do we express them? We
only express our good intentions in the
way that Muhammad taught us.
Sallallah.aii was
the opposite of
or what negates sincerity and good
intentions is a
what negates good actions
is what innovation.
So these two come together and these are
the first two. This is the first lesson
Allah teaches the messenger.
He begins with what? Recite read. The
second lesson
stand.
The second lesson implement
these two now go together.
Subhanahu waala
and you know
[Arabic recitation]